votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 followers sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirait
talents.com les amis c'est mathieu de
leur bon vous demandez certainement
pourquoi j'ai des lunettes de soleil
vous avez raison nous autres les
les amis jeanne alité de marque pour
regarder l'émission il m'a accompagné
manqué 12 cordes clair qu'avec un niveau
ça c'est un vrai ami fallait un petit
peu ensemble c'est important de se
regarder
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
là
hu sans viser
[Musique]
amadou qui se tenait à nice
heureusement d'une journée le comprends
pas fini mais c'est à dire on a fait le
ban c'était pareil et de la charcuterie
y en a en suisse en prime on adore bon
ben 10 la bonne nouvelle avec l'oeil
rouge peut être que je vois que tu vaux
rien 7e là c'est que du tout je voyais
pas la gueule de mcginn quart d'heure ça
fait bon j'ai entendu ça c'est le
problème peut pas être aussi est sourd
pourtant quelques jours
même bien avoir des vrais moments de
propos du coup je suis pas seule chine
notamment avec winnie est peut-être une
rolls magali berne a essayé de selliers
chic bon je me casse
pas plus il est là ils sont là ils sont
là ils sont tous là ça reparte et ce
soir c'est un petit homme que je mets
avant ma crème
donc c'est halo de la grande et de
framboise qui sont superbes robes il est
tout de suite et je les adore donc ça
c'est avant la craie l arnaque
ça va bien du côté un peu ouais ou un
peu écoliers un peu ma britney spears
voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
à qui sont bons qu'ils sont beaux ils
sont beaux et oui les amis allez on va
reprendre ses droits
les ennemis enfin la photo la photo la
photo la photo attention rendent caméras
ils sont tous là mathieu myriam machine
catherine luc sébastien daniel winnik
qui prend la photo 1
[Applaudissements]
ah là là ils sont trop verts au but en
dessous beyoncé puis en dessous vos
joueurs que vous n'êtes que madame des
cartes non mais vous avez votre match
vous à votre agent de sécurité oui votre
base votre match
rothen n'a pas gardé avec vivendi en
train de manger entre deux tétées trop
bien tu vois mon lit je crois que c'est
ma drogue maintenant je vais vous ayez
des des uniformes ce débardeur un peu
centre est un peu sympa tu vois avec
marc et madfrog derrière matthieu
delormeau
tu vois jamais je ne terminais mon
si on te paye les pipeaux n'a vraiment
bien bien rigolé gère les lunettes
notamment au visage
et avant de faire de tpm des bonnes
résolutions je me resterait un petit peu
reprend des forces unies notamment son
corps d'été et la semaine prochaine nous
présente la chaufferette hivernale et
l'aspirateur à deux tubes
voilà on vous me laisse très pop et les
machins croyez-moi ça c'est très très
bon goût explosion au magic ce podium on
l'appelle tout dit fou dit à l'écouté
joyeux de litchi extrême casas bahia n'a
voulu s'y sent très bon aussi je les
adore bon en tout cas ça donne envie de
voyager naturel faut passer une photo de
soi disant tu te rends compte si bal'ouf
et latin challenge il vécut poteau de
vie à 47 ans en existait morini bosc
on a tous
[Musique]